band barred their accounts gone dark
from the chairman of the british
national party to organizations
like britain first and the national
front
today facebook said these people and
their groups
had no place on their platform facebook
said these were
individuals and organizations who spread
hate or attack or call for the exclusion
of others
on the basis of who they are those who
proclaim a violent or hateful mission
or are engaged in acts of hate or
violence will no longer be allowed a
presence on facebook
or instagram facebook said it shut down
the accounts at midday today
but campaigners say that it is too
little
too late we should be happy that
facebook has taken this action this is
the right thing to do
but i do think that it's coming far too
late because what's happened is over the
last few years we've seen that these
groups have managed to use
mainstream platforms particularly
facebook to gain extremely large
followings online
so in a certain sense the damage has
already been done
facebook says it is working to fight
what it calls online organized hate
a month ago it permanently banned
english defense league founder tommy
robinson who had a huge following
today the edl itself was banned they
told us
our page has never had any content
removed because we kept within the
guidelines
freedom of expression has been eroded
you can't express yourself
unless it's the way they want you to
think
they are just a private company and
they're deciding the boundaries of
speech
they're not doing that on the basis of
law they're doing that on the basis of
a combination of the terms and
conditions and political pressure and
that
that is not really the right way for us
to police
the boundaries of free expression
they might be banned on facebook and
instagram but some of the groups are
still on other social media platforms
the government says that's why there
needs to be a global effort
to clear extremist content and it needs
to happen
now caterina totsi sky news